will mean where did you grow up I grew
up in Detroit Michigan and yes it was
automotive town still is but not like it
was and I was uh I was artistic kid you
know coming up you know I did all the
little school plays and and then in the
glee clubs and all that kind of stuff
but I also was in the sports and I left
the business entertainment business who
you want to call it that back in those
days I'm left footing got into sports
and I played baseball Little League
baseball and then I when I got to high
school I ran track and played a little
football but then when I went to college
I was totally into football and track
and I actually had a football and track
scholarship someone a few of my peers or
people from that age that still don't
know student loans I got problems with
my body of course some injuries but I
don't owe anybody any money like that
hmm yeah that might be a bit better
problem yeah yeah but yeah Detroit
Detroit was uh Detroit at that time was
an interesting place because it was a
lot of stuff I was a kid but the whole
Motown thing and and at one point
Detroit was one of the foremost theater
towns in the country believe it or not
and a lot of the shows would start out
in Detroit and go to Broadway or go
wherever they were gonna go like out
east or whatever but Detroit was one of
those places and musically a prince you
know one of his first places that he
really started becoming famous and got
off on was in Detroit and he always
talked about how Detroit was a special
place for him you know and I remember
seeing Prince way back when he first
started I'm like this guy's weird but
he's good I mean you know planning and
simile all this boy he's strange-looking
you know little guy and he was really
good
you know so he kind of basically
starting Detroit's and he tried this
Detroit as a is coming back now which is
good you know it's really coming back I
was there for the holidays and driving
downtown and around different parts of
Detroit I was just amazed it has changed
because I went to Wayne State University
in Detroit which is in the heart of the
city and when I went it was this modern
you know thirty five forty thousand
students college in the heart of the
ghetto I mean it's completely surrounded
by the ghetto so you would be over here
on this side of the street you had
college professors none other said you
had cracky it's it was like okay it's
different but it was it was interesting
yeah coming up in Detroit you know where
you pushed more towards sports or I mean
because you probably saw a lot of people
that you grew up with that maybe had a
plan for what they're gonna do after
high school
and I know acting is always sort of
especially maybe we're more of a
masculine I'm not saying it's not a
masculine pursuit but but something that
was considered more of what you know
acceptable maybe at that time for a man
to do well no I I just saw I always
liked playing sports as a kid because I
was just I was just into it I was uh I
was the youngest of four and my oldest I
have three older sisters and so that was
something that I did my father was very
athletic my father was very athletic and
you know I say to this day my father was
way ahead of his time you know had my
father came up 20-30 years later he
probably would have played professional
baseball I mean my father was that
athletic and that tremendous of an
athlete so I picked up a lot of my
athletic talents from him and but sports
was always my I love sports I I was
naturally into the arts I mean I used to
when I say the arts I drew
and paint it and I ended up having a
minor in that in college and my
specialty in heart was pastels and
pencil and people say well you know you
know you doesn't do oil painting or that
guy said well playing sports in college
to do oil painting it takes time because
you can't just do this and lay it on you
have to really be intricate so in
college I was always on the road
traveling or whatever so in art I mean I
had to do it in school of course but my
best work was always you know pastel in
pencil which was a little quicker to do
and coming up as a kid I was in all of
the after-school programs because at
that point they used to have
after-school programs for all of the
kids that are gifted in in our music and
all that kind of stuff even though we
had it in our school system at that time
and it's kind of unfortunate now the way
things are knives you know a lot of
that's gone we don't have a lot of those
programs anymore because you know they
cut the school budgets and everything
and a lot of kids I remember they used
to have in high school ahead Orchestra
one two and three in and had all kind of
choral groups and stuff in high school
so it was like gone now also another
thing I was really into was carpentry
and stuff as far as shop class I mean my
mother was always a phrase you know he's
going to end up being that and being a
carpenter or being a person in a trade
right now is you can make a ton of money
and they're bringing that back now and
and they're finding that you know a lot
of the people that went to college or
wanted to go to college that didn't
quite make it were more mechanically
inclined as opposed to being college
preparatory inclined okay I happen to be
I think both but I matter of fact I'll
say this and brag about it I've made my
own voiceover booth for my voice-over
work I do as an actor oh and I bought
some plans and it's when people see this
that know me well they're gonna be like
oh here you go you'd launch it into that
because I'm always talking about this
stuff you know he's a you stop
Ragan I said but I bought plans online
for this thing and once I bought the
plans you know I sat back and said oh I
got so excited I went out and got all
this equipment and everything and all I
got to I got stuff all it gave you a
list of things to get like the panels
and in the the sound absorption stuff
for the walls to keep the sound out I
got the two by fours I got all this
stuff to make a four by a six foot or
seven foot booth which you recorded and
once I bought the stuff I had it in my
living room in my apartment and I sat
there and I said I don't know what the
hell I'm doing with all this [ __ ] in
here and I mean my girlfriend came by
says why I know what you do this I'm
like I bought these plans and it'll work
and all my friends and all the guys are
coming right everybody laughs at me he
was like with Noah
you know when built he built Noah built
the ark high everybody was partying and
laughing at him because he was out there
building now I can custom me everybody
come my laughs and I called my mother up
you know my mother I said I said my I
said I don't know why I did that she
says what you need to do is you need to
start at the beginning of the other plan
start from the first part of the plans
and take it step by step now this is my
mother telling me this and I'm like oh
okay so they give you a DVD and I
watched the DVD about a hundred times
I'm like okay okay and she said you were
good in shop you got straight A's in
that stuff you can do it so I started
building this thing you always start
with the foundation as we know the
foundation is where we start in
everything whatever you do whether you
always have to start where at the
beginning and it's always the foundation
you know as an actor as a film person
you know like yourself you have to start
at the beginning and start okay I have
to start learning from the beginning so
I did that and I built the booth and I
had everybody it was shocked they were
late you actually built this damn thing
and I was more shocked than ever I said
no I did not was like I actually built
it and I mean this is a full booth and I
do professional work out
booth Wow yeah so I mean deviated from
where we started but I mean this is kind
of thing that you know as a person of in
the arts that's how I got started in the
business that's how I ended up branching
into this and I couldn't do anything
else I got fired from every every real
job I've had was there a point in your
life early on or whenever where you said
this is all I'm gonna be able to do is
be an actor mm-hmm yeah I had that I had
that you want to call it an epiphany I
had that way back I had it when I got
out of college I my father had a bowling
buddy who who was a claims adjuster for
Aetna life insurance and mr. blackwell
you know he got me a job coming out of
school for Aetna and the funny thing is
Edna I was supposed to be outside claim
trip which means that I was supposed to
working off his half the time and go out
and take pictures and go do stuff out in
the field it's ironic that I couldn't
handle the the freedom of being out like
I didn't have a discipline at that point
to handle the freedom of being out on
the road for the job I couldn't handle
it and it was really crazy is in what I
do now it's all led you know because I'm
self-employed I mean you know so and
I've been that way for years but I
couldn't I couldn't stay on that job
because I recognized that it wasn't for
me and I was like okay this is really
weird I can't do this and the day I quit
that job was the day that I was supposed
to be there for a meeting and I missed a
meeting because I was just really at my
in my little apartment I was just like
man this is just not I'm not gonna make
it
I mean I was floundering like that in my
mind at that point and I was like I'm
not gonna make you so I was late coming
into the office when I got there my boss
is like well don't worry
you missed a meeting I said there's no
need for that he says what do you mean
no need for that I said I quit so I had
you know my dictaphone and my look
and all my stuff that you use out in the
field I put it on his desk I said I quit
he said you quit what do you mean you
quit I said I quit so they really like
me on the job because you know my
personality people love me on the job
because I hate everybody laughing all
the time and I told him I said this is
not from me so he said wait a minute
wait a minute wait here
he took me he was - he was my supervisor
he took me to the manager of the floor
and in in corporate America the higher
you go up the more important and more
prestigious and bigger your job so they
took me floor by floor to all these
different people the superintendent and
they hand me an is offer these plush
offices and they sitting at grilling me
you can't leave why are you leaving
what are you doing that we trained you
we did this I said I just I'm sorry I
can't do this and this is that that
affirmative action kind of thing you
know what he said they're gonna think we
we ran you out and said no no no no no
no no no no no I'll sign any papers you
want saying that you would you I said
you the sweetest nicest people they were
pretty nice people I'm like no no no no
no this is not me they took me all the
way up to the top to the president he's
sitting behind this big giant desk you
know like in the movies where they're
these big executives he had that kind of
desk and I'm sitting there like this
little young guy twenty-two years old
sitting like this and he says what's
going on I said I'm supposed to be in
show business
he says what I said I'm supposed to be
in show business
he said why is that I said well I talked
to a buddy of mine who's not in the
business at all and he said that if
there was one job you could do for the
rest of your life that no matter what
happened or if somebody put a gun up to
your head and said quit that job or I'll
blow your head off
he said you supposed to say shoot
meaning this is it and my buddy told me
says think about it
because he's real he still is to this
day he's very philosophical guy and he
said go home and just think on it pray
on it or whatever you want to do and I
did
and he said call me tomorrow and I
called him the next day I said I want to
be an actor and a singer and all that I
want to be an entertainment business so
he said well then you need to let your
job know I went in and quit the job my
parents naturally freaked out they were
like what but that was that was what I
had to do and I was engaged at the time
and I lost my fiancee because she had my
life all mapped out for me I was
supposed to do that job because being a
claims adjuster for from in corporate
America you basically are a law clerk
technically because you compile all the
information for a different claim or
whatever and I was handling some real
big claims and you take that and you
give it to the corporate attorney who
goes into court to try to fight the
other side because either they don't
want to pay a lot of money or they don't
want to pay any money at all so they go
into court on it so that was basically
what the job was so she said you're
gonna do this job you either gonna get
your masters in business or you gonna
get you gonna go to law school and she
had it all mapped out I said I can't do
this this is just I mean I was having a
problem with my stomach I mean you know
I was like losing sleep and everything I
was like just I said I can't do this I
quit that whole thing she dumped me and
it seemed like overnight things started
happening and I went to a this is a
really crazy but I went out to dinner
with a couple of friends and they were
consoling me about it and I'm like I
might have made the wrong mistake I
might have done something I might I
should have done what she said they said
no and this is this is crazy but I
started looking at the silverware on the
table as they were talking to me
consoling me and I was just looking at
the silverware and all of a sudden I
came up I said within the next couple of
years I'm gonna be doing commercials and
I'm gonna be doing stuff and I'm gonna
be in music I'm gonna be singing in the
acting on stage I mean they said really
that's it yeah within the next couple of
years I was doing that I got in a show
in Detroit call this is your Detroit it
was a thirty minute
show you remember - I don't know you
might be too young to remember the Mitch
Miller and all that you know all that
kind of stuff the singers and all of
that like Lawrence Welk it all together
I mean this is way before all our time
but it was one of those kind of things
and we did a 30 minute show about the
good things about Detroit which should
have lasted about two minutes when we
stretched it up to 30 minutes and I sang
and did all this and I actually had
studied see how my politically trained I
started I met a guy but all by accident
friend of Mines mother owns an antique
shop
and I wanted to take voice lessons so
this man came in mr. Harris came in to
buy an antique chair or something and
she said I've seen you in here before
the lady that always says what do you do
he says well I'm a music teacher you
know one of the high schools and he said
I teach you know voice and this and that
so uh my son's best friend you know he's
like my son he wants to take music
lessons voice lessons well giving my
number I studied with this man Society
years and I learned operatic technique
and everything and then he sent me to
his teacher who was like an Italian man
who had actually trained and worked with
Pavarotti and all those people you know
in Italy so I became operated be trained
I never really used it because foreign
languages is always one of my weaknesses
so I was like wow so I actually had an
audition my teacher said okay I want you
to go audition for the mint
they're coming in town I said the
Metropolitan Opera he says you won't get
it because you don't know the language
but I want them to hear you so here I am
you know big afro wearing a tank top and
some and some jeans and you know I
buffed at the time because I'm just
coming out of playing sports so I go to
this audition the only one like me there
you know what I'm saying looking just
like this I walk in there so all of
these people you know these divas and
all these guys and I mean I for people
really like that you know like a
stereotype they all in there me me me me
me me me me doing that so I walk in so
the first question they ask you they say
to me is uh excuse me but you
be in the wrong place I said well is
this way holding the auditions for the
Metropolitan they said yes so I said
well this is what I'm here for so the
people stopped it's like 'i'm hood me
everybody a I'm old enough to remember
that right so so what happened was they
said oh so the person came out to say
okay who's next all of the people are
saying let him go cuz they want to have
a good laugh said let him go said oh you
sure you all been neatly said no no you
go so the people looked at me the lady
looked at me I go into the into the into
the auditorium where they had a piano on
stage and everybody is looking at me you
know over a big panel of people from the
men and the Detroit Opera and the
Metropolitan Opera all these people from
the symphony and everything is sitting
in there and they all looking at me like
so what are you gonna sing you had to do
a dramatic piece and you had to do a
light comedic piece I said I'm going to
sing for my dramatic piece at least is
hwadam are from Tusker and i'm going to
do
una forty-four lagrima from Elia I did
more and they like really they said well
your honor which one do first I said oh
well I want to do the the lighter piece
first to warm up and I started singing
know your keys for rooms and or any
people looking at me like this
I'm saying that anyone like looking
around like this then I sang my dramatic
few it looks a lot of still air and I
hit the high seat which is the tenor I'm
a tenor I'm a dramatic tenor which means
I have a the big tenor voice okay
there's a light lyric tenor and I'm the
heavier tenor that's almost like a
baritone which is the rare voice so they
hear me hit this high seat and the man
from the met jumps up and he runs up to
the edge of the stage that all these
starts to be good Italian and I look at
him I say huh
oh you don't speaker to tell you signals
being none of that so that was the end
of my Metropolitan Opera experience in
my
his aspirations because I couldn't get
the language so I used it for musical
theater and I was singing in all the
musicals around Detroit and I mean I was
singing you know Oklahoma oh you know
called the voice was strong enough to do
if you can do it you can do anything
else it's like it's like ballet and
dance you know ballet if you notice
people that study ballet when they do
jazz or whatever you could see the
difference their stuff is just their
line and all of that is just so much
more pronounced so I did musical theater
I got an agent who came to see me in a
musical and that's when I got my
commercial thing going what happened
when you walked past all the people that
were there that when you know what I
left
hmm they were all like looking at me
like and one guy came up and says you
have the most incredible voice but see
my teachers trained me I mean I did I
trained for eight years and and and the
thing is my car broke down and I would
like kiss the bus and in Detroit
catching a bus is like being you know
you remember Mad Max you know you know I
did I did in the wilderness you know
where you just out there I mean getting
a bus ride in Detroit is crazy so I
would be a in the cold going to my music
lessons and I had it I ended up taking a
little job I took a job as a working at
a halfway house for some little kids you
know just to sustain myself when I
substitute talk just to keep the money
flowing while I trained and you know my
parents and everybody was like uh he's
just flipped out all the way you know
because they didn't they didn't think I
was serious or I had really they didn't
didn't believe what I believe and I felt
it I mean I knew what I was supposed to
be doing so when I got my first agent my
first agent as a commercial actor and
doing TV and film stuff when I went in
the interview I had a friend of mine
sister take my first headshots and I
mean she was in she was in for
hagh Rafi school so she get those you
know those pictures like that she know
the war like you know the prison
pictures yeah [ __ ] cuz she didn't know
any better than I had those and I had to
it was a GQ thing thank you
GQ look you know and when I took the
pictures to that agent who saw me in the
in the in the musical because she came
on gave me a card and I was only one she
gave a car too and all of course other
actors and everything like they were mad
oh yeah
so I went to see her and she says do you
have any pictures were you smiling
I said no she's a smile I said wow you
got a beautiful smile yeah I want you to
go see this photographer I said well
she's I know you don't have much money
would go see this photographer tell him
I sent you
he's going to shoot you this guy shot me
some new headshots why I'm like this the
whole thing and she had me come back so
she she handed me a script she said okay
read this it was a Kentucky Fried
Chicken commercial script so I had never
done anything like this so I read the
script she says you're gonna be good
you're gonna be good in the commercials
one day you're gonna be good but you'll
never do voiceover I'm like oh what's
the voiceover she told me I said oh so
she signed me and everything and sent me
out on stuff but it kind of upset me the
fact that she said I would never do
voiceover because it's like how do you
know I never do voiceover you know so at
that point it became a burnin up session
to learn voiceover so as fate or God or
whatever who would have it I moved into
an apartment where this guy down the
hall from me named Dennis was an
engineer at a recording studio and we've
met in the laundry room and he said hey
you new in the building I said oh yeah
he said so what do you do I said well
try to be an actor or whatever and he
said oh he said what else you do I said
well that's basically it I got a little
regular job I said but I really want to
try to do this voiceover stuff he says
really he says when you finish your
laundry knock on my apartment down I'm
down the hall from me because I know
where you had I'm knocked on it open his
door he's got a full recording studio I
said what is it he says I work at a
where we do voiceovers he taught me how
to do voiceovers right so when I left
Detroit I moved to Chicago I became one
of the top African American voiceover
artists in Chicago I did everything from
McDonald's to amico which was gasoline I
don't know if they still around they
don't call it amico now I did every
product that you had pepto-bismol I did
everything and before I moved out of
Chicago I was going back and forth from
Chicago to San Francisco I became the
voice of Bank of America oh wow general
market and I became the voices is
banking on America Bank of America so
all those 15 years was 15 years at that
point 15 years later I became one of the
top voice of the guys in Chicago and it
got to the point where I knew it was
time for me to leave by this time my
parents were like believing me like hey
you're doing well I was making a real
nice living and I said well it's time
for me to move to LA and they were like
why are you doing so well you you
working you know cuz that was a complete
effort you know the [ __ ] up and
everything else so you you've been doing
this all these years now I'm like no
it's time to go I came out to LA and I
would come back and forth and the first
thing I did I had an audition for a TV
show I booked it and it was for life
goes on no show remember about the boy
yeah yeah I booked it I booked that and
when I was I was in the makeup room in
the trailer Patti LuPone and all the
stars when they've been made up they
were real nice welcome to the show and
she said so how long have you been out
in LA I just got here two weeks ago and
this is my first audition everybody said
what I did a recurring on the show get a
couple episodes on the show and whatnot
and then I started doing other stuff and
then it became a tug of war between here
and Chicago so eventually I went back to
Chicago cuz I was involved with another
woman who didn't want to leave because
she was running her own insurance
company so I'm like I said we need to
move out
no I'm making much more than you so that
that whole situation that engagement
went out the window so I said you know
I'm just a complete loser when it comes
to you know getting married so I said
well maybe it's time to focus on the
career so I came here and I started
working and working and then we went on
strike and all my commercial stuff
happened to be running out at the same
time when we went on strike
I had partied all my money away here
hanging out and doing all kind of crazy
stuff in LA so I said okay I gotta find
a little job so I took a little
part-time little hustle job which turned
out to be like a seven-year job almost
for Nielson and I was handing out movie
passes and stuff so that was a nice way
you know to get out to me people was
flexible enough from auditions and I met
a lot of women and I've met a lot of
women because it's easy see when a guy
has a has something he's selling it's
easy you disarm women you know but when
you walk up like hey like uh excuse me
you know that wall comes up he's like
hey would you like to see movie so I've
met a lot of women like that and it's
segue into relationships you know that
works it works you know so that's what
basically happened on that and then
after a few years of that I started
really clicking in the business again
here and I didn't have time to do it and
then at that point you know I wouldn't
even show up for it they eventually had
to fire me from that job and and all the
people on the job and all those people
you know who I work for they well I'm
silly like that's cool I'm gonna do this
stuff and so I've been doing um I've
been doing commercial and TV and films
to have ever since as far as that um
I've done over 200 commercials 200
on-camera commercials you know over the
years and then I've done quite a few
voiceovers in fact I have uh I'm on the
rocky and bullwinkle or the new rocky
and bullwinkle cartoons I play this
character called a fetus it's a
billionaire
little squirrel I like that squirrel you
got there hanging out with it
that moose with the three corner head
you know yeah I like him
sabe que ting that character nyan also
did a I'm also on Barbie's Dreamhouse I
play a couple of characters on there and
then I'm on this little show called a
wild grinders it's kind of like the
little rascals on skateboards and I play
the little dog on the show and he's on a
skateboard
so I mean I do that I don't I haven't
done those recently but I got those
still running and whatnot but it's been
a good experience you know I mean you
mentioned a few times kind of having to
choose between what you wanted to do in
life in a relationship right and I think
there's a lot of pressure on people
especially under 30 to make that choice
and to get settled down if there's
someone listening right now and let's
suppose they have something that's a
good offer or they have something that's
promising in one city and then they have
someone in another city that they
probably still care about and a life
that's quote-unquote planned out but
they're on the on the fence what what
kind of like let's say big brother
advice would you give someone follow
your heart you have to always follow
your heart because if somebody has your
life planned out for you that's a
problem right there because unless you
have your life planned out the same way
they have it planned out it's not gonna
work because eventually you're gonna you
know you heard that you always hear
about people outgrowing each other
well they've we we all grew each other
what that means is you didn't outgrow
them you just grew up you know and you
know I'm saying I mean it's not like you
don't care I love them it's just that
you you've evolved when I say grow up
you've you evolved into who you are who
you want to be and if it's not in that
cookie cutter kind of thing that they
have planned for you and you know you
they have you boxed in here
you know have you boxed in and you grow
and you outside of that box
that's constantly so you have to you
have to be who you who you are in in in
and hopefully that person or someone
else will be in line with what you're
doing because you got to be happy I mean
nothing worse than being in a
relationship I've been there where you
know you're trying to be something that
you're not you're trying to conform to
somebody else's expectations trying to
be what they want you to be it's not
gonna work because eventually you're
gonna you're gonna boat from that you're
gonna run from that because the real you
is always gonna come forward you can't
be phony in a relationship you can't
it's impossible because eventually you
go you can't be you can't act in a
relationship you can act on stage you
can act you know wherever else but you
can't act in a relationship you can't be
this person yes dear whatever you do you
can't do that but so long eventually
you're gonna just say oh [ __ ] this I
can't do this and then you know it's
gonna it's gonna explode so you have to
you know you have to be you and and if
it means that you have to you know let
that relationship go then you have to
let it go I mean life is hard as we all
know I mean you can't you can't be what
somebody else wants you to be you have
to be who you want to be and like I said
if it doesn't fit what they want you to
be to then it's not gonna work do you
think creative people have a tougher
time in a relationship then and I'm not
saying people that have a nine-to-five
aren't creative oh yeah but but people
that choose creativity as their as their
vocation as well as their passion sort
of thing yeah why why do you think that
is because to be an artist of whatever
type whether you're painter a musician
or whatever you know rapper or whatever
to be that you have to really really
dedicate yourself to that to be good in
it because there's competition and you
know when you first start out
no competition yeah yeah he is because
in this world and then being a
professional out here you have to be
really really into what you do now I'm
going to tell you something personally I
used to smoke a lot of weed and get high
back way back years ago and I had a
buddy of mine who was actually the guys
selling me the weed back home pull me
aside I mean I'm at his place
beautiful beautiful houses you know he
pulls me got all the buddies sitting
around you know smoking we can I used to
love smoking weed now don't get me wrong
I loved it but he pulled me aside and he
said come here I want to talk to you so
all the guys sitting and say oh he's
gonna take him to the good stuff the
good stash should know another room he
got me another room he says you know
what he said me and you've been friends
since the fifth grade he said you just
you live in Chicago you going to
Hollywood
he said you can't be getting high like
this out there he said the competition
is heavy you're gonna be going up
against the major people for stuff he
said you got to focus more you got to
get out of this and that stuck to me
that's duct mm length Wow
and he says I don't have to sell you
none of this stuff I got customers all
over buying my weed and whatever I don't
have to do that with you me and you were
like best friends like brothers you say
you got a thing in terms of you know
sacrificing something to get what you
want to go Wow so shortly after that I
quit smoking weed it's been over 27
years now Wow you know and I smoked so
much that people were like you quit that
late yeah because I had to say you know
what he was right and once I stopped
doing that things started really falling
into place my focus and my concentration
got stronger and it's not because okay
my mind wasn't cloudy some weed because
I've been smoking weed was fun to me you
know and and but it became a point where
okay it's just it's a thing of
discipline so getting back to what you
were saying it's all about it's all
about being who you are and being honest
with yourself about who you are
and not let anybody sidetrack you you
can't be you can't be what a way for a
girlfriend or if you're a woman or
whatever or a guy with a boyfriend or
whatever you can't let somebody take you
away from who you are and what you want
to be because being an artist is not a
job it's a calling it's a life we all
artistic your artistic we all are
artists this is a life for us and you
have to explain to people and see nine
to five people they have a tendency to
see things in the sense of a job okay
yeah well we get jobs I mean I just did
a job and I got a couple coming up in
the business but it's my life it's not
like okay I'm gonna cut it off you know
yeah I cut it off a lot of times when I
get home cuz I'm watching the Lakers or
somebody or you know watching something
on TV or something or sitting around you
know doing something or reading a book
or something yeah you have to unwind and
relax and get away from stuff at times
but you have to know who you are you
have to know who you are and you have to
say okay this is Who I am
you gotta accept me for who I am well I
got to go and that happened to me a
couple of times you know what he said
okay this is not it for me I'm like hey
now the first one probably still hates
me when I was real young the last one we
became friends and we talk all the time
you know and she's in Chicago she makes
a couple of hundred three or four
hundred thousand a year got a beautiful
house in Chicago got a Mercedes and all
that and driving around she's very
attractive and she's the businesswoman
I'm like hey I'm happy for you I'm proud
of you you know and most of my family
and friends and I grew up with the 95
people so I don't have any problem with
that I just Know Who I am and I know
what's best for me because like I say I
got fired from every real a real 95 job
I've ever had I got fired from my first
job was a paperboy they fired me what
they fire you all because I wanted to
play baseball all my friends are playing
baseball and I'm out with
wagon drop him throwing papers up on the
porch and all my friends hit baseball
I'm like I'm 12 years old you know so I
didn't ever said okay I got to figure
out a way you did not get fried
necessarily but I gotta figure out a way
to do is literally this job as possible
so there was a Dairy Queen on the end of
my route and I had in dairy but it was
like 10 Center with him and I had little
buddies in the neighborhood younger kids
go with me on my route and I would lay
on my wagon and point to the houses
build and run to take the papers and
some of them so one of my customers
called a man into paper station my
manager and he came out and he says hey
what are you doing
setup like this and he says see me at
the end of the day and I knew you know
when I went back you know to the place I
say oh man I'm in some serious trouble I
got fired so I didn't go home and tell
my mom and daddy that was right
naturally you know being 12 you kind of
stupid so what you do is like okay I
can't tell mom and daddy I got fired so
I would leave the house every day and go
up to the school you know the little
playground in school and I was sitting
over on the side at the playground for
two three hours every day sit there like
I was on my route and finally one day at
rain it was raining cats and dogs I mean
it wasn't raining and so I was like oh
so I was leaving out and my dad said oh
you can't go out in the rain I'm gonna
go with you I'm gonna help you do your
route today and you know I was always in
trouble for something so my father says
wait a minute wait a minute wait wait
wait you all are going to do your route
I'm like he says what happened so I had
to let him know I got fired
said you got fired he said well I said
three weeks ago my mama said three weeks
ago they say why don't you where will
you go when you leave the house every
day I said I was going up to the school
up there with my little school I was
going up there sitting on the playground
they looked at me like you have to be
out of your mind no that's
that's what I would do it I mean you
know so I mean I'm telling you and that
started a long long life of getting
fired from every job I mean every
regular job it for having me from NRG
the job I was doing the movie pans they
fired me we were talking about nine to
five jobs and I wanted to go to
something that I've heard other people
talk about and I've also experienced in
the past and that is you take the job
and they know you do other things
outside of there and they know that okay
that's fine and especially in LA most
people aren't just that job but then
they start to get weird with you
co-workers start to get weird and now we
have social media and they can kind of
like say oh oh I see and it starts to
change on you and that's when I've seen
people get pushed out the door or they
start to make you sign things that
you're not making other employees sign
like you won't use your phone during and
you don't but you start to see that the
the parameters are different for you for
some reason I don't know if you've
experienced that I've heard that from
other people well let me say this I
didn't experience that because I was way
god by the time that those kind of
things started happening but I know
people that did experience that and they
would come to me the person that had
never experienced that because who had
been long gone and I would tell them I
say well that's telling you it's time to
go hmm without them having to tell you
that see when when when stuff like that
starts happening to somebody that's an
artist that's working 9:00 to 5:00 and
don't get me wrong you have to be able
to sustain yourself and to survive so if
you need that work the job and you know
people say well yeah should I quit my
job I say only if you can sustain
yourself without that job I say
otherwise you need that job because see
to do what we do as an artist this is
not today an age of like three four
hundred years ago when you know somebody
would be starving you know and a little
hamlet somewhere in England or somewhere
you know them days are over you have to
be able sustain yourself if you out here
on the street and you don't have a place
to stay you're not an artist at that
point you out here fighting for your
life so if you have a job
stay there but you got to try to find a
job that's gonna allow you to pursue
your craft and know the real hard to
find like I mentioned the Nielson thing
the Nielson thing was cool in that sense
because if you had something to do you
go do your audition or job or whatever
might not show up that day as long as
you got those passes out or whatever you
know they didn't have a problem with
that so you got to pretty much find a
job like that that's why a lot of
artists and actors and people are
waiters and servers and all kinds of
stuff like that because those are the
kind of jobs that people understand
enough and those are what I call
romantic jobs for actors and other the
few jobs that industry higher-ups have
no problem with an actor being there
doing because when I say romantic I mean
in the sense that all of the top people
or whatever at one point or another were
waiting tables since or valet you know
those are kind of jobs that top people
see a young aspiring actor doing like oh
okay
they remember their experience that that
it's not Jung but he's gonna really grow
and all that's nice but they must but
the industry people are less patient
with people working in corporate America
or behind a desk somewhere the industry
people are less patient with that
because they know the difficulty of
getting out of those jobs and see those
jobs you know they always starts
somebody off from what my friends have
told me they always start somebody off
oh sure you can take off you got an
audition go ahead after a few auditions
they started they start coming down on
the light what do you really you really
have to go or we really need you here to
do this so that then that affects the
actor with the agency what not then you
know they have to say well I can't make
it because I would meeting that's when
the agents and people will say okay what
are you gonna do I can't be doing my job
here submitting you speak it up for you
to get in and say hey she's really good
well he's tops he need to see him and
you can't make it when I set the
audition now see so it starts working
like that starts working like that so it
becomes a point where if an actor or a
singer or whatever you are in the
industry if you're really really serious
about doing this in this business you
got to eventually say okay I got to
leave that yeah and if it means like if
you making 40 or 50 60 thousand or
whatever oh no a hundred thousand or
whatever on a corporate job
and you really really aspire to be in
this business you might have to leave
that job and go get you a job making $12
an hour to be able to do that and that
takes a hell of a lot to do because I
mean if you married or have children or
something it becomes difficult because
once you have children or something like
that and I and it doesn't matter to me
whether you're in the arts or whatever
to me if you have children they come
first the business is all that comes
after that no matter how much I love
acting or whatever if I got a bunch of
kids or I got a child that child comes
first
and that's the way it should be when
anybody so it's it's a real tough thing
to do it's a tough nut to crack and you
have to just finally just be real with
yourself like I was saying earlier you
can't be with somebody that's not gonna
let you be you this is this is the thing
that's hard about this job we do and
that we're not even talking about the
actual rejection which is 99.9% of it
you know getting rejected and how people
you know I've had friends they were much
more talented than me they had to leave
the business because they couldn't
handle the rejection and I'm like wow
and when I first got it I I had a little
trouble at first and then I had a I had
somebody in the business my mentor who
passed away years ago he told me he says
you better get over that he said because
you don't get rejected a hell of a lot
more than you're gonna get accepted he
says so now
yeah and I've learned this idea I mean
you know we all I'm not OCD and say oh
well I've mastered that I don't
I can handle rejection now I get you
times because you're human I mean
everybody real you know human being and
sometimes it hit you
sometimes I hit you not only just
effects it damn that job was gonna pay
me a lot of money
other times he hit you wow I thought I
was really good and that's that's the
part I want to play and not even
considering any money it's just affected
your your artistic thing was like man I
could really get into that role that's a
challenging role that would be really
good for me to do that and you don't get
it so it hits you in a lot of ways so so
you just got it eventually and it's a
theme I keep going back to got to be
true to yourself you got to be true to
yourself you got to be true to yourself
not only as far as a job you got to be
true to yourself as far as can I handle
what I'm doing can I handle this can I
handle the fact that I'm gonna not have
a lot of money at certain points or I'm
not gonna get a job I'm gonna be
depressed about [ __ ] can I handle this
and you have to just finally say okay
yes I can no I can't
and all these friends I had to left the
business and whatnot when I see them or
I go home you know for the holidays
right or Facebook or they some weeks
it's day in church we'll talk I don't I
don't hold anything against them as
fries them not being an actor you're not
an actor anymore so I can't relate to
you oh these are friends these are
people what I love and care for and I
tell people I say hey and what I always
do is most of my friends would have to
leave the business out of here most of
them go home and don't have any money
and cable to get home I provide
everybody a way to get home
I've sent many friends home not on the
ground cuz I wouldn't do that to him
good if you coming from LA to Chicago or
Detroit or New York that's a hell of a
long ride doesn't make you wanna keys
them
so I fly them home I mean I don't send
people home one-way tickets and I have
people say you always send in somebody
on my said I do that because if they
broker whatever and they can't get out
of
they need to go I love him I had a
friend who left she drove she drove out
I said are you gonna make any that
conscious I'm gonna make it and she said
well I'm gonna need about $200 I said
okay I came with $200 and other people
said you gave her $200 yeah she got to
go home she like Dorothy she's got to go
home she clicking them heels and get the
hell out of this to go go
how about help me get out of here
because that's what you have to do and
people thank me and that's harm and I
said I would hope you would do it for me
if that were the case I sent people home
I mean I'm sending two or three people
home a year
you have to realize who you are what you
can do and and see me I know there's
nothing else I can do so I have no I
burnt all I purposely burned all my
bridges leaving Detroit
do you think most people go home because
of the rejection or they have very
strong pulls from friends and family and
it's comfort it's safe I'll miss them
and it's it's not always that way here
especially if you're working a little
survival job in the gig industry that's
not it's not that it's all of that it's
not just the fact that you can't do your
your acting or whatever it's all of
those factors it's all of that I mean
that's why that's why I say it's this is
this is a calling to me this is a
calling to be this see when you when
it's a calling there's nothing that can
take you away from it I mean you know
you get sick of whatever
like my mother fell and hurt herself now
if I had to go and I went home for a
couple of weeks to tend to my mother if
I had to go home to take care of my
mother I would do that cuz he family
comes first you know if I had to say
okay I'm gonna have to go home for a
while I will do that see so it's not
like no no no if this is if this is an
emergency situation that always to me
takes precedence over this because you
can't I couldn't be happy or really
concentrate knowing that my mama or
somebody needs me and they helpless I
couldn't you know you can't you can't
function so I mean I would do that but
if it's about the fact that you know the
pool like I dated a girl that was here
from Chicago and we went to see a movie
and in at the Sherman Oaks Galleria and
when we left a movie she got a call from
her from her mother anyway having a
cookout in the backyard or something so
this is like we went to see her like a
early matinee you know around 12 or
something like that so after the movie
was always around two o'clock or
whatever back in Chicago was four
o'clock and it was on I think of
Saturday or something and her mother
called oh because oh we got barbecue we
got potato salad we got all
stuff Oh everybody asking about you and
we were walking going to you know you we
walk into the car you know you've been
in the Galleria right so we were walking
to the car on the ground and then she
stopped dead in her tracks and start
talking and then all of a sudden she
said okay I'll call you back mom I'll
call you back
she hung up on the phone and stopped
broke down start crying so naturally
people who walking pass it what did you
do but people looking at me like did you
hit her
did you I'm like that I'm just standing
here she started crying and said I want
to go home and we got in the car and she
cried and cried we didn't even we didn't
even take off we just sat in the car and
she said what should I do I said you
should go home she said really I said go
home I say you you you need to go home
because you feeling that she said but I
don't I said don't worry about me or
your agents and all these people you got
to do what's best for you if it means
being in this business be in this
business if it means going Hong Kong she
went home made her old sweetheart had a
kid
beautiful little girl and he ran off and
left it but this another's doing you
know and we talk all the time you know
what she said oh yeah you know I said
well now is he taking care of his
responsibility is he giving you they got
divorced I say are you getting your
alimony in it oh yeah oh you don't okay
but but it's like you have to you have
to realize who you are what you can do
and and see me I know there's nothing
else I can do so I have no I burnt all I
purposely burned all my bridges leaving
Detroit because the last real job I had
in Detroit you know while I was still
studying my stuff I quit on them and
actually they had to terminate me
because I moved I went to Chicago and
wouldn't come back I took a leave of
absence
certified social worker for the state of
Michigan I didn't go back so my boss had
to I had to come back and I went to the
job and she's crying while she's writing
the termination papers all the people in
this Inn and I'm hugging them and it's
gonna be all right I don't want to get
fired
oh that's okay they said I was hugging
and consoling them and they had to fire
me and then they want to I said no no no
they said you could have taken a
long-term leave I said no I said I
needed to burn this bridge I can't go
back over this bridge there's alligators
in that moat down there and they if I
try to cut through the water they gonna
chew me up I can't go over this bridge I
burnt that bridge down see I had to burn
them down because I said this is what I
have to do this is what I have to do and
people in this industry as you know we
driven we driven now I don't I don't put
everything into this I mean like I said
when I get home I mean I put everything
into this when I'm working auditioning
or whatever and all that when I get home
I say okay I'm putting that aside I've
learned that over the years okay I gotta
put that to the side so I watched
football basketball oh I do do all kind
of other stuff other than the business
you know I don't get high so I can't do
like a lot of my friends that smoke weed
oh yeah I don't do that anymore so I
have to just do other stuff but you have
to get away from it sometimes you know
and you have to just do that but like
like like like we was saying there's
always gonna be a pool of some type
there's always gonna be a pool and I
mean even when I got in the business I
had so much I have so many people
calling me crazy when I first got in it
because they didn't understand what I
was doing because this is all away he's
a flake anyway
you know he's you know I had a girl that
you know I knew I was at a party and she
found out I was doing aspiring for this
early and she had gone out and went to
New York with the Alvin Ailey Dance
Company and whatnot and she didn't make
it
so I was at a party and I'm sitting at a
table with her and her her boyfriend you
know and she says you gonna try to do
what she said oh you'll never make it
because I couldn't make it so if I
couldn't make it I know you can't and I
was like sitting there like okay and I
had people doing me like that then I
would have I would meet women you know
you know I would try to date him or
whatever and they said Oh what do you do
for a living I said well I'm an actor
they said oh you are what if I seen you
in or have you whatever you done you
know and if I'm if I'm saying well I
really haven't done much then now you
know it was like he's a loser they
looked at me and I had that that L on my
forehead you know for them which is the
loser you know and I actually had women
whispering he's a bum he's a loser I
mean I had all kind of stuff I'm like
okay all right and and as the years went
on and I start doing stuff I would get
few and front questions like that now I
don't get that anymore and if I ever get
any of those kind of questions somebody
said well whatever you done uh what can
I see you in I can give him a list I
said oh I was a recurring character um
proxy and Rec I was a police chief I
I got a commercial right now running for
Liberty Mutual that's running every two
seconds I can't go anywhere without
people not recognizing me we just bleed
me the airport everybody nobody ever did
mutual get them like Crayola okay so
what I say and I get like I say very few
questions like that because it's been 30
years I mean 30 years and I you know I
used to have people say well why don't
you use your
I mean with you College and I'll say
well I've been I went to school for like
what 17 years you started what side I
guess I said I went all until I was like
21 22 you know how I was a year behind
because I played sports and had to drop
classes because I was always traveling
you know so I was I was like a I was
like a five year college graduated not a
four year you know so that's my scarlet
letter you know he came out in five
instead of four oh but you know it's
like seventeen years of school I said
okay I went through that life for 17
years I've been doing this 30 so are you
they said oh I said yeah it's like I'm
out of this stuff but no I you know it's
like now now I don't have that problem
with women problem I got now is I got
women trying to take my money okay
that's a whole that's another subject
altogether you know I mean try to get
this money because they know I got some
money see so now somebody calling me
here oh okay just keep the kid who does
here I knew it was her you said
something that triggered my memory of
two different interviews I saw with
artists and both those artists came from
a small town and they said where they
came from had very supportive like a
very supportive network however it was
never okay to try to rise above the
group because if you did then they said
oh you think you're better than us so
can you talk about that because I think
it's a very real part of people's
upbringing or or their they have a great
support system but there is an unspoken
or maybe spoken thing where oh you don't
want to act like yours to better than us
or smarter than us or who do you think
you are to do this over us and have just
the normal life that we had back here in
our small town okay let me say this I
don't get that because most of the
people that are close to me that are
friends from home
they know what I've gone through and the
struggles I've had and it's kind of
funny that I'm being serious they
whatever resentment they might have for
me they don't bring it to me because
they know what I've been through I mean
I literally I literally was on foot for
a number of years where my car I had old
beat-up cars and whatnot because my
music lessons my voice lessons I would
study my first well I had a teacher
before the man I got she had me come
once a week and I couldn't really
sustain what she was teaching me you
know as far as my vocal training and
when I got with mr. Harris he said uh
let me tell you something you got to
come at least two to three times a week
he says cuz I got a build this voice up
I got a bill your this whole thing up so
I said well wasn't I supposed to be
singing a little that mask and using my
diaphragm he says yeah he said but still
got to come through your throat yes so
we got to build that up he says and I
want you to come check me out he's a
singing himself and check some of my
people out at this concert we give him
well I went and I was like wow so he
said it's not cheap so you got to make
up your mind as far as how much you want
to spend and how much you really want to
do this so it became a point where I was
catching buses and and and standing at
the bus stops and sub-zero and freezing
like this you know and my friends and
people that were close to me knew this
and saw me saw me and my first fiance
hey whatever you want to call it my
teacher had lived not far from her and I
was standing at a bus stop and you know
the bus stall and
I saw her cart it was uh it was like a
Kentucky Fried she loved chicken it was
a Kentucky Fried Chicken behind where I
was at I'm standing here on the street
and busted all like this and there was a
Kentucky Fried Chicken Meehan and I saw
her car
I'm sat in saw her car go through the
drive-thru at the Kentucky Fried Chicken
and it comes out on the side where I am
it goes in it goes in this way and it
goes around right and it comes out this
way on this side of me and I'm standing
here like this and I literally know knew
that she and her sister or somebody in
the car were like looking at me and I
didn't look over cuz it was a point
where I was like okay this is who I am
and this is what I got to do they drove
off that was that was that was that was
a hard thing for me to deal with that
was a hard thing for me to deal with but
I said okay you know this is what I have
to deal with and and so people that I
said that we're close to me my parents
and sisters and good friends I never got
them from them because they knew and
they still know what I'm going through
so if nothing else they say man Wow
I have people that are a really
impressed with the fact that I've been
doing this this long and I've been fired
a couple times in this too but you
always go to the next job but well but
they've been impressed with the fact
that I've done this this long and I make
it a nice living bleed me and people out
running to I haven't seen in years say
wow you're doing that that's hard in it
I said well look at me this look like I
lost any meals oh they say you have put
on a little weight I said yeah I say you
don't put on away from not eating if you
put away from eating I said so I'm doing
pretty good you know and I don't say
this to anybody or anything but over the
last ten whenever
years I paid more money per for you to
nail on me I mean lot more but I don't
carry myself like that and I don't I may
be one reason why they don't have a real
problem with me is because I don't carry
myself pumpless anything anybody that
sees me that I knew coming up from
school or I run into somewhere or
whatever they say you still the same
that's it
yeah because I'm secure and Who I am and
I don't have to pretend to be something
or I don't have to put on airs because
this is just what I do
I said this is my life this is my my job
okay this is what I do so I don't feel
this any more important or any more
special than what you do and and I treat
people like that I'm like oh I'm happy
my niece wanted to get into this and
she's like I don't I said look just cuz
I'm in this and you like what I'm doing
if this is not for you do what do what
you do and do you come on you money I
love you you like my little child I'm oh
do you I said I don't want to see you
suffering this she's got a regular job
doing quite well I'm like I'm do you I
don't I don't care what you do as long
as you do you and you happy doing you
then your success see you you you people
say well I don't feel successful at what
y-you doing you you you you got a job
you got a house you got this you got
whatever you happy in what you do you
look well you're doing well that's
success it doesn't matter how much money
you make it it's what you do that makes
you happy and and what you are good at
doing and you doing it you know it's
just what it is you have to be you I
keep stressing that over and over you
have to do you you can't be something
that somebody else wants you to be it'll
never work
you
that one that yeah shooter my whatever
jump off the damn top of the build into
something I had a friend do that by the
way and then but but you got it you got
to be you and and I don't I don't I
don't let people trip on me about you
know the fact that you know I'm better
cuz I don't come off like that I don't
come off like that with anybody I give
people advice on the business I help
people
I'm not gonna give my thousand dollars I
mean you know I mean now I'm giving
money than my family more much more than
that because that's my family I've given
some friends you know stuff like that
but not just not a random woman that you
know got on a nice outfit and kind of
high heels and you know look good I'm
like come on I mean I've been with
good-looking women my whole life I've
always even when I was sighs in the
first grade I thought I was suave and
debonair when I had my lunch pail with
Roy Rogers you know sitting on and I'm
like yeah that's the Roy Rogers lunch
meal you know I mean I've always been a
beautiful women that's just me and I'm
not so beautiful you know but but it's
like it's just the way it is you know so
I don't let that trip I don't let that
stuff get to me you know
you said you were robbed and it changed
you oh yeah I was robbed a couple of
times I was robbed
the first time I was robbed I was robbed
I was doing a I was in read I was doing
a play on the east side of Detroit which
is crazy it's much better than I put it
the theater was on the east side of
Detroit and my car was out of course so
I had to catch two buses to get home and
I was standing at the bus stop waiting
for the bus which it's not like here or
somewhere like a subway train running
every two minutes and Detroit it's like
I told it's like Mad Max in the
Thunderdome you got there late you know
so I was waiting for the bus and it was
kind of cold and I was like this you
know and and I felt somebody and I kind
of heard somebody coming from this side
and I kind of said don't look over I
like oh it stuck something in my side
and he wasn't a finger cuz it felt like
steel he said okay give me your money I
said okay all right but I don't really
have no money so what you talking about
you know ain't no money I don't have any
money I got some little change and I got
a bus ticket that's all I get what
you're doing over here and I said I'm
rehearsing a play I'm an actor and
refreshing the show now he engaged me
that long and he said well give me what
you got nothing a like 32 citizen he
said that all you got I said yeah how's
it don't shoot me I said I'm just trying
to make it and he said all right all
right soon and he said just don't don't
don't move I said I'm not I'm not gonna
do nothing and he started walking off
and I kind of saw him and I said don't
you want the bus ticket and he looked at
me and I saw him I look right at him at
that point he says no fool
how you gonna get all
and that was like so really what I saw
after that and I felt with that whole
situation was that was somebody that
lived around there that probably has
seen me before but people don't just
randomly walk up to somebody and the
funny thing is after that I didn't tell
anybody what I wasn't about to tell my
mom and then whoa hell no and I was
going with a little girl that time I
wouldn't tell her so I was like no I
just didn't ever say nothing but the
first thing somebody would says you
can't go back over there I'm like what
no no it's a good party show okay and I
knew I was hooked there I'm a hooked
nobody ever bothered me after that
because this guy probably told all them
around there yeah no money your actor
over here at this place leave him alone
nobody ever bother you that really woke
me up to like wow this is what I really
want on this dedicated but it's like
when my friends say if they don't shoot
you that was that kind of situation
where it's like okay you either do this
or you get shot so I'm like I'm not
gonna stop coming over here now somebody
else might rob me and I hope to have a
few more coins in my pocket but I was
broke I mean I would literally broke so
I was like I had like 32 centers
something in the bus ticket cuz you know
we had bus tickets you get a strip of
bus tickets and you know you get a
transfer when you get on the bus and I
had a got to transfer with the bus
ticket and and second time I got robbed
was in a McDonald's I was living I
wasn't doing a show at the time but I
was living on the other side of town and
my dad was sick in the hospital and my
mother
and I actually had my car at that point
and my mother was at the hospital all
day she said well you know what I'm I
just don't feel good you know being at
the house by myself can you come over
and spend the night at the house on hope
of course hey my own apartment that's oh
yeah so she said well look I've been at
the hospital all day I don't have no
food I haven't cooked maybe you ought to
stop at McDonald's
something get you something I said oh
okay and I stopped at the McDonald's I
went through the drive-through his
current late at night and I ordered my
food and the girls said well can you
pull over cuz you know we're cooking and
bring it out to you I said okay so I'm
sitting in the car it's cold I'm running
my gas I'm like oh wait a minute so I
said well I'm gonna go inside so I came
inside and she's like I said I'm the guy
you told the pullover she's all okay
so they said we haven't even got it
ready yet so so I'm stand at the counter
and there's like four of us four guys at
the counter you know getting our food
and the little boy in front of me you
know the little McDonald's boy he's like
looking at me and all of a sudden he
looks over like this and he starts doing
this and I'm looking at him like look
you got I'm looking like he's it and I
look over guy got a sawed-off shotgun
pointed right at my head and he's
telling me raise your hands [ __ ]
my hands up and these guys proceeded to
rob the McDonald's and what he did was
it was - one guy came in on the other
side the other door the backup guy and
he uses me as a shield and he's got the
gun under my arm I like my arms up he
puts the gun under here and he's got the
gun right in the face of that little boy
and he says empty the register and the
little boy I'm naturally uh he's an
empty the register so the manager of
female at this time she's down here and
the guy with the sawed-off he says okay
empty all the registers she empties all
the registers except mine and then he
said okay open the safe and she says
well I can't I don't have a combination
that's a drop box you say no you can
open the safe she says I can't open it
they come every night and get the money
the security come every night and get
the money I can't open it he said you
lie he says get out on the ground
[ __ ] she gets down on the ground on the
Florida other place and he leans over
the counter
and he [ __ ] the gun and he puts it on
the side he says I'm gonna tell you I'm
ask you one last time
open the safe so she's like this and
she's a she starts crying please don't
kill me I can't hoping to save I got a
baby at home please just me and my baby
please please and I'm like this and I'm
just looking and I'm just like oh my god
and I got to got behind me with the
little boy like this and I'm like this
and I'm like oh I'm like this and all of
a sudden the guy
uncocks the gun and the next thing on my
mind is thank God be professionals
professionals don't want to shoot
anybody see I found that out from being
in Detroit around the hood what
professionals don't shoot anybody they
want to get in and get out so he says ok
we're finished getting the money she
jumps up she gets the money she gets
down to my register little boy money and
we said give him the money give him the
money we yelling and screaming and they
said shut up we didn't shut up give me
the money give him the money
it was just pandemonium so this manager
she knocks him out the way goes in his
register and get the money put it in one
of the big McDonald's bags and hand it
to the guy so the first guy out of the
place is the guy that had to piss to
undermine the last guy out he says
anybody trying to think I'm gonna come
back and kill everybody he comes down
the line of us didn't rob us he comes
down the line of us and takes to the gun
across all our backs small of my back I
had this gun go down the small of my
back and I'm telling you my life flash
before my eyes when people say all my
life slash I went from being a baby
[ __ ] my pants in my diaper all the
way up to the it was just like that I'm
like oh and I'm like oh god oh oh like
this and he left out when he left out he
took off running I looked they took over
and all of the customers jumped over the
counter and we could all be anything by
this time the cops came in cuz they put
they push the silent alarm
and I got to the house and my mother
said oh she said you didn't get your
food I'm like no I didn't get it so she
says I what's wrong I said we got stuck
up at McDonald's my mother's like oh
okay
my mother got mad at me when I said I
have to remember what that felt like
because one day I'm gonna have to act
and have to recreate that experience my
mother got mad at me but that's what
happened what you and that damn acting
and that's what I really finally
realized this is it this is where I was
going to be that was the first
experience of me getting robbed with the
guy with the gun take my load $0.32 the
second one was that and that's when I
said I'm in all the way because all I'm
thinking about at one point during the
robbery is like I am this this is weird
I got I have to remember this I just did
a thing on shooter TV show shooter where
I played a bank guard and I get shot in
the in the episode and they put a squid
Peck home in everything they lied to me
oh is it not gonna hurt it's gonna be
just said teeny-weeny pinch it would
learn the answer that squid hurt and I
get shot in the scene and I fall over
but I but but even though I'm like in
and I'm belligerent to the guy he says
all right oh man
cuz the flashback from the early 70s or
whatever and in it's a flashback scene
so I said well I didn't I didn't I
didn't later I said get on the grounds
here my back here I got a bad hip and a
bad back I can't get down there
he said I told you to get on the ground
I said I can't do with that so I didn't
laid out in career I'm not laying down
now so he shoots me but at that point
I'm recalling a lot of that experience
of that and we did one take and the
director says that was so real and we
broke for lunch and he said that was wow
I looked at it that was that was real I
said yeah I said I told him a story at
mcdonnell's he says what I said yeah
I've been stuck up a couple of town man
I've been shot at before all comes tough
it's like you trying to write a pass
it's like you know Bar Mitzvah is like
get shot get stabbed and stabbed yeah I
got stabbed in the girls prison yeah I
worked it 100 I said what were you doing
there
I was uh I was working as a that was my
last job yeah that was my last job
before I finally was like I'm done and I
left I ran out of Detroit mood of
Chicago I said okay I I you know I had a
I had a Social Work degree I had a minor
in art you know my major in school with
Social Work so after the corporate thing
I was taking these part-time jobs and
all kind of little jobs to be able to do
my thing in the study okay so my last
year I worked at a place out in the
suburb of Detroit it was called a
lock-up
it was a it was a place I don't want to
mention a name but yeah it was a
Catholic organization and this is where
the rich folk was sending their kids I
made daughters oh she's away at boarding
school
no she locked up and a lot of those rich
girls were girls that were run off
runaways and we had a situation where I
worked at afternoon I was a I was a
supervisor on the afternoon shift so
when I came I started with 3:30 or
something like that I came in two came
into the job and I pull up in my car and
I got all these police cars and fire
trucks I'm like yeah whatever so I go
inside and the day girl day person she's
and she throws the thing you know the
log can I got a look at you know you
gotta you know log in and everything
it's the state kind of job so she just
throws a blob like she runs out so you
know I'm like okay in in so the cops are
saying well you know they're locked up
in the day room and we got to go in and
bust it down and we're gonna do this and
the fireman says I got these hydraulic
hoses we gonna hold him I said okay stop
she can't do that well who are you I
said I'm the manager I'm gonna have to
noon manage
you can't do that no we can do I said no
I said I'm the legal guardian state
guardian of these girls you under my
jurisdiction which is everywhere state -
here - you can't do it
sin I'm gonna go in and talk to him
so they boarded up got shared that's it
let me come in in the day room when the
rec room lass it let me come in and talk
to you no I said let me come in and talk
to you I promise I'm just coming in I
went in there for about 15 minutes and
so what's going on what a friend I said
well you know what was doing I said come
on no you know you came they called him
and they fried him he was a counselor he
was he was the night supervisor [ __ ]
see they had to have somebody there 24
hours a day with him so he was the one
that midnight all he had to do was just
make sure they were okay and then they
locked up him then they're in rooms two
in the room with these doors this thick
they didn't have bars then doors this
thick way it's like you can't shoot
through that or nothing okay they locked
up so I talked to girls down and one of
the girls had like a chair leg with the
look that long screw and sharp screw and
I talked him down and when I opened the
door to say okay they coming out this
cop said get him he rushed him and one
of the girls thought I set him up she
tried to stab me here and she caught me
in the side okay so she ended up born I
didn't press charges but they I was
forced to press charges they sent her to
women's detention at that point and I
rode up and I brought us growed up and I
got that cop suspended and the fireman I
got I got him suspended and he wasn't
had him suspended it's like because that
was a violation of the state you can't
do that they were gonna hold you know
the hoses that they put out fires they
were gonna put these hoses on those
little girls do you know to power those
hoses they're pretty strong yeah they
can they can break bone they can knock
these girls and break through her
girls no we got to get him out of sin
I'm gonna get him out of there so they
like me you know you know because I was
accurate I used to perform stuff and
show them stuff and teach them little
acting stuff so they like me and I knew
that no so that's what happened on that
but right after that I say you know what
brother you got to go see what you have
been robbed twice it was that's what
it's like okay you gotta go so I said
it's telling me to leave so I love write
a couple of months later I left and went
to Chicago I was in that's with
everything and I'm in my first big
commercial with a James Brown The
Godfather so wow wow that was an
experience in itself how did you know
that you were good at acting because I
was good as a kid see see when I was
like in the early grades we did did a
school play of the Aladdin and his magic
lamp and I was so good that the teacher
wanted me to play Aladdin but I said I
don't play Atlantan I want to play the
evil Sultan and I remember and I mean
I'm in like the third or fourth grade
and she's like really I never forget
that cuz she told my mother when my
mother came to the show she says he
didn't want he should have played to
leave but he didn't want that he wanted
to play this part and I was good as did
yes I did all that stuff
and the people were crazy and the
teacher says your son is something else
and I remember my mother's telling me
she said you know when you were in the
fifth grade you read like a 10th grader
and she said when you got a chance grade
you really like a fifth grade but always
joke about desert huh so but what I'm
saying is I knew that and people knew
they were like wow I mean I was singing
you know and stuff from I was a little
boy soprano and I oh I got teased
terribly by the boys in class I mean you
know cuz uh we had to sing that little
song from The Music Man
and I sang the song there were bears on
the hill and I never heard ringing no I
never heard them at all till there was
you Jeff seid a music man thanks how are
ya Robert Preston and Shirley Jones I
had a crush on Shirley Jones from
Oklahoma Oh Shirley Jones she's so
beautiful
and sing so they sang they do it so I
sang that in class with a little girl
and all the boys was just on me because
I was a beautiful little little
lightweight little voice and my teachers
just playing like oh and she said you
ought to be in this business one day mr.
Pyatt
she's a little old lady you ought to be
in show business
oh I mean that's look here and for men
and then I had the thing where I had to
I wasn't a bad kid but I was always in
[ __ ] you know I was always doing stuff
it would always scare my folks so when
my mom and daddy would be at work in the
summer I understand the house until my
mama got home in the afternoon see my
mother was a teacher so she taught
summer school and summer school let out
at like 12:00 1:00 o'clock you know
because it's not food there's half a day
so I would have to stay in the house cuz
I'm like yeah so you know as a little
kid you get up early in the morning so I
would be up and it was - it was two TV
shows and I watched one was Rita bells
prize movie which came on at like eight
o'clock in the morning and Rita Bell was
this lady who was an aspiring actress
that never made it and I would watch all
of the Hollywood musicals the musicals
in all of the comedies she would play
those and then in the afternoon around
12:00 Bill Kennedy bill Kennedy's
Showtime and Bill Kennedy was an actor
from Hollywood who never made it and he
would play the cowboy pictures and the
gangster movies which I loved so
Humphrey Bogart and James Cagney and
John Wayne the cowboy pictures I saw
those so I would watch these for a
couple of years like that so I became
pretty much and I'm like a movie
historian now I've won two game show
answered movie trivia and I can tell you
almost anything about movies old movies
I know everything people like wow how
did you notice I said because I was
watching this stuff so I even knew then
that I wanted to be in this business I
knew I'm like man I want to do that I
want to do that but I never said
anything anybody so eventually when I
got out of school I played sports all
the way through school when I got out
and I went pro and I didn't make it I
got hurt and I'm glad I did because
that's crazy
I mean it's I've lost a couple of
friends who you know from that CET thing
you know when they mine leaves and they
they go crazy from from tackling and
stuff I've lost a couple of friends that
died so I'm like man I wouldn't suppose
it'd make it I mean I was always hurt in
crime I didn't mean now I'm like thank
you Lord because that was crazy
but I knew I was supposed to be doing
this and I just fell into it like I said
when I when I when I told my fiance I
said I got to go you know you know she
said well I gotta go right men the job
you know I quit you know you know all
the new hustle jobs in all through the
years I got fired from all of them
because I would not show up because of
the business you know my parents were
like okay and when I finally got in the
show that they didn't totally disown me
but they just were like really
disappointed in me and I was living on
my own and and I was struggling and
starving and he came to see me in a show
and that's where my parents said good
and it was really funny how I was on a
Sunday and all of these people came up
to me and literally pushed my parents
back because they were all over me and
my mama said you coming by for dinner
right I said yeah of course Sunday
dinner I said yeah so I went back with a
matinee show that son the only one show
and when I got there my mother was like
I believe you my daddy said yeah and I
used to complain to him all the time
about the the business in Detroit I'm
not getting it audition I'm not getting
this I'm not getting that I hate this
job I just got stabbed you know he says
why don't you leave why don't you go to
New York why don't you go to California
that's where your stuff is he said is
they don't a lot in Chicago at that
point said why don't you go into one of
those places stop complaining and leave
I'm like I left and I went to Chicago
first and I had a lot of relatives there
and I stayed with a couple of my
relatives and then I met the girl that I
was throwing I was married the other one
and I stayed my whole thing was to stay
in Chicago long enough I'd already got
my sag card I wanted to get one
commercial they were shooting a lot of
TV shows at that point because Chicago
was hot you know really hot at that
point and I said okay I want to get one
TV show on one commercial and then I'm
gonna go to California I ended up
standing there almost 15 years and I did
ton of shows 3040 commercials all kind
of stuff and what made me leave Chicago
and I was ready to like I don't know
she's not leaving but I went into my
agency one day and they were doing a
voiceover job for Gatorade and when I
came in the receptionist said he's here
and I'm like yeah yeah I'm here so I I
have three agents in there they all came
out of the office and was standing in
the doorway looking like this they said
yeah yeah the specs for the spot is on
the wall you know telling you we want
this you know telling you what you have
to do for the for the audition so I
looked at the wall and it says we're
looking for a Romijn Johnson type we has
to be this has to be funny he has to be
clever spontaneous he has to have a
great sense of humor which is you know
me and I'm like huh and they all like
yeah and I said oh no and that's when I
said to myself is is time to go it
looking for somebody like me but they're
not talking about me for the job cuz I
had been working for those people I've
done it several Gatorade commercials
Gatorade I mean radio all counts I'd
done work for they had used me to the
point where they couldn't use me they
wanted somebody like me but not me so it
was time to go in my agents knew it's
time to go so I didn't just abruptly
just leave I said okay let me go
got out early so I went and I was
traveling back and forth for about a
year so then finally I came out here in
97 and stayed 11 months and for tax
purposes my my tax man says well you got
to spend at least one month back there
to try to claim some stuff so I went
back and then I stayed there until June
of 98 and then I moved State June of 98
and I came out back to Chicago then in
following year in June of 1999 I just
completely moved so I've been here since
it'll be almost 20 years in jail uh-huh
and that was it you know and that's
that's when things really got nuts
Romijn we interviewed Bill Duke or the
second time he gave us a wonderful
interview both times and we had a video
we wanted to play and get your reaction
okay here we go
I think where all of us are everything
and people say why can you say that I'm
a woman with a child I'm not a murderer
okay
suppose somebody just came up and made
sure a baby in the head with a hammer
well what would you call your response
to that if you pick that hammer up no
one's saying you're a murderer no one's
saying you're anything but you're
everything oh and if you're hired to do
a job the director doesn't hire you to
act like that person
the director hires you to become that
person right and that's something that
most people understand about acting I
think it's not I don't that word is
annoying because it means you're
pretending acting is not pretending
acting is becoming it's surrendering to
the spirit of whatever you're that
character you're describing is so thing
called stage fright that's when you're
in the middle you've given part of
yourself up to be the character but your
ego and your fear and paranoia is
watching how you give it up and tries to
control the shape of that giving up
right but real actors like the ones that
I adore and the Kate Winslet's and the
Meryl Streep's and denzel's when he's
really in it and the Sam Jackson's and
philip Seymour Hoffman's and the Jeffrey
writes and when those people go there
there's no there's nobody there except
that character and that's admirable it
takes courage people to understand
because sometimes you're not control
you're you're you want a ride if the
trust and the person you trust the
director to say that I ride right what
do you think cuz you don't stand outside
and look at your ride you ride and
that's what real great actors do
Flip Seymour Hoffman's my favorite
actress of all time I think he was
brilliant
oh yeah you can someone still be great
and have stage fright they can be great
and have stage fright making me really
good at have stage fright right but to
surrender totally to the moment and to
totally respond to what the other person
that you're acting with is doing that's
her that takes courage you're not
watching yourself anymore you're
watching the person you're with and the
scene you're not watching how you react
to what they do you're responding it
like we're talking right now I'm not
trying to be a special anything I'm just
responding to what you're asking me and
that's what acting should be one of my
great acting teachers when I was a very
young actor I asked a similar question
he said I'm gonna make it real simple
for you
he sent us like falling into darkness Oh
imagine just falling into darkness
backward no control of your landing I
was right you're gonna be caught or not
just a fault embraceable supposes I
rocked back there or suppose there's a I
don't know no pillows and just hard
floor the writer is saying to you I want
you to fall into darkness backward I'm
giving you all the description the
director Anaya of who the character is
we've had rehearsals and discussions
about who this human being is I do not
want you to describe them to me I want
you to become them by falling into
darkness backward right can you do that
oh I agree with him I would take it a
step further on one of them when he says
be coming instead of instead of it
acting you become the person I mean yeah
it's just a kind of wordplay but I was
saying instead of becoming you be the
person you be what you are
I've studied um I think I've studied
every major technique stanislavski's and
Method because they all come from
standing off Stanislavski well they all
come from Stanislavski every form of or
method or style you know are originates
the modern acting originates from
Stanislaus
and I've studied all of them and the one
I recognised to me that works best for
me I mean you use bits and pieces of
everything but the one that I'm the one
technique that I really used more of or
already is Meisner because Meisner is is
you be you are that person and one thing
that they always stress to us in Meisner
when I was studying Meisner was don't
ever say my character my character wants
to do this so my character is that or
this that no yes I am this I am that
see which which takes you beyond
becoming because see to me when you
become when you're becoming while you to
become this character to me you're still
in it I'm agree with everything
basically you you still outside somewhat
of the character you know you're still
kind of outside but to be that the
character then you're inside all the way
and that's part of what he's saying
about falling backwards I mean you
fought you into it to the point where
it's just you and you just let go and
trust yourself that's what he's saying
but um I agree he's a hell of an actor
and director and and it's kind of funny
when he mentioned Denzel Washington
about when Denzel Mets him stuff when he
goes into it sometimes in greatest
Denzel Washington here sometimes I could
see he's working and when he did fences
and to be honest to give him he was
directing as well as acting so he had to
come outside of it to to work with the
other people and especially Viola Davis
who to me is just she's tremendous she's
she's like she's like Tim newer all
right you said hey just say that but
like she's like the newer Meryl Streep
you know and it's quite a few I mean
Cate Blanchett that's quite a few and
you know I love Daniel day-lewis
Daniel day-lewis to me is the one it
becomes he is more than any other actor
to me as we talked early he is Hawkeye
you know he is crazy I was bill or
whatever from Gangs of New York he is
that he is the oil oil baron that throws
that bowling ball at that boy you know
and actually try to hurt him because
he's so far in that you know he he
frightens those people and and all of
those actors like Leonardo DiCaprio and
Paul Dana and all them all of them said
that after working with him and seeing
how he works that took him to a whole
nother level especially Leonardo
DiCaprio and he did some really nice
stuff when he was a kid you know
basketball tires yeah really nice stuff
but after gangs in New York he took a
step he took a step up to me and when he
did revenant he wasn't he wasn't acting
he wasn't becoming
he was that character I mean for anybody
that might not have seen the movie on
when when he goes over the cliff after
the the Indian or whatever were chasing
him and the big that big horse falls
over and then the horse breaks his neck
and eyes and he's screwed up well
to survive well he cuts debt and guts
dead horse and then takes his clothes
off to make sure he can get that warmth
of the horse he gets inside of that
thing and I mean I'm like I mean I'm
sure you know and they probably would
they didn't have a real horse I don't
believe I don't think he but the fact
that he was able to convey that and get
that into it and when the bear attacked
him I mean you can't just act you can't
say well okay I'm gonna act you have to
be that person at that point he was that
guy getting savage didn't scraped and
beat and just chewed on by that bear I
mean is this was like wow and and he won
the Oscar because he was so far gone
it's like last year another one of my
favorite actors is Gary Oldman Gary
Oldman no matter what he does Gary
Oldman is that person he's not acting or
pretending he is that person even when
he plays Commissioner Gordon in the
Batman franchise he he was Commissioner
Gordon I mean he's done some brilliant I
mean and he just did Winston Churchill I
mean I was just mesmerized he won an
Oscar but I mean I was completely like
wow completely just mesmerized by him
cuz he was he he became Winston
Churchill and I tell you who I haven't
seen it yet but this movie Vice with
Christian Bale saw it you saw it and and
from what I'm hearing
he was Dick Cheney excellent and Dick
Cheney I'm sorry I mean whoever's
watching this to change his diabolical
evil person I mean I mean you know hey I
mean but he became Dick Cheney in the
previews I saw I saw I saw a movie a
couple of weeks ago I came to know what
it was but they showed the preview of
ice and to let me know in the show
just how far in watching the watching
the trailer of it at the theater when
it's over you can tell when somebody
really connects when everybody in the
theater just give me to watch the movie
with airforces you know when you and you
get it you hit that buzz in the in the
audience you know sometimes you it'll be
a laughter on something really silly and
funny kind of trailer you know they
connect so you laugh but when I saw that
everyone's like oh because we saw Dick
Cheney and then you know the thing where
you know you sitting in the truck he's
at home she was his friend you know I
mean what did it happen like that is not
I mean you know but it's just it was
just really all the way in and and and I
think that's what the whole thing about
acting is or being an actor and which is
what I find so so great about this and
you can never ever master this you never
master this and people said what do you
mean you don't master no you don't ever
master this you always you always have
something to learn it's not like it's
not like well got that down you ain't
because you're only as good as your last
performance and especially so in theater
theater theater theater is the one place
where you get instant gratification and
instant critique film you know you can
do 100 takes or whatever why they could
edit it together and then six months
later or whatever when they release it
then you find out or you'll get your
critique but on stage you get it
immediately so anybody and I've been
there it's like all actors well you
don't you do a great performance one
night and there's like the next night
yeah well you know they really like me
they love me you know IDI was tremendous
and the next night fall flat on your
face which is a lesson to learn it's
like you have to commit every moment you
out there the performance the
performance is gonna be different no to
performance I've been in stuff and plays
and shows and stuff with people
especially musicals it always is
different but most places and I've had
actors and younger actors and people
saying even some older actors say I
didn't do this right that it's not like
it was last night no it's not like that
it's gonna be different which is the
challenge of it and which to me is like
the blessing and everything of it in
fact that
yeah I can't master this because I've
always been the type coming up where I
would get bored with stuff especially in
school I would get bored with it by the
time I got to college and I went over
some of the stains same stuff I had done
in high school I was like okay this is
college I mean ten I'm gonna go over
this I know this okay and a lot of that
stuff they wouldn't give me a new
perspective on it it wasn't given me oh
this is a new way to do it which would
excite me to the point of Oh is
something different that's all the same
so eventually I'm like okay but when I
got into this each time is different
which thrills to this day I'm thrilled
it's different these time and I got to
make sure that I don't screw it up or if
I do so be it
I gotta use that you know when I first
got into business if I made a mistake or
if somebody I knew we were younger
actors you make a mistake you might show
the audience that you make a mistake
because your reaction to the mistake but
when you are that person when you are a
character in you all the way in you can
deal with that because you make mistakes
you make mistakes when we talking I mean
I've bitched a couple of times here but
that's real yeah it's not like okay I
gotta go back over that line because I
said that wrong no no you have to work
through that it's to the point now and I
tried I mean hopefully it works but I
try when I make a mistake doing
something live then I use it to the
point where the audience doesn't know I
made a mistake
that's when you really locked in and
when you are that character when it's
something that you are and and you're
gonna stumble
I know actors did fall apart after this
stumble oh I stumbled over the line it's
like you stumble over the lines all day
long you something walking in here you
know you hit your foot on the door or
something you know you your elbow hits
it's like you're not just walking in
there I didn't hit anything that was
perfect
oh you make mistakes all over that's
that's what makes it real and when you
do that and you just continue I was in
the show years ago where I played um I
played Skeeter to jump oh okay I was
gonna say about this this show years ago
where I played this character Skeeter
the junkie and and my partner in the
scene was undercover cop
who I didn't know was undercover cop so
when I finally realized and he finally
lets me know he's a cop
and I've given him the information he
wants he's supposed to throw the little
bag of you know dope you know which he I
had yeah give me the dope with our
cheese all right he's gonna just throw
it down and I'm supposed to pick it up
and do that whole thing you know and so
the guy that played the scene with me he
got into it so so crazy because he had
his family they had everything you know
he was like all in that he threw the
dope off the stage I mean literally
threw it off the stage and he's like oh
no he just looked like this and I looked
and saw it and did to sing
I had to have the dough so in the
audience he threw it right in the front
row by some about some ladies who's
sitting there by the lake and she's like
looking out like this and the audience
everybody's looking and everybody's like
and I felt everybody looking like what
AM what am i got what is he gonna do I
calmly stayed in character kept saying a
line and you know whatever as adult as a
junkie walked off the stage went down
there by that lady's foot grabbed the
dope walk back up on the stage and
finish the scene and when we left the
stage at the end of that scene they just
went crazy because it was like what am I
gonna do I got to play the scene and
this is real so the my dope is over
there so I couldn't just act like okay
um well the dope is down there so let me
act like in mind that I really have it
no no no no no I went down there walked
off that stage and went down and picked
that dope up said my lines some of them
down there and came up to here I gave
you all the news get ready and I put the
little thing around mine went back up on
stage did that took yeah I mean the sing
was over basically after that but the
audience is like whoa because I didn't
let it throw me to the point where I was
like because I was always I was locked
into the character even though I'm
locked in I know that okay I got to get
this dope cuz that's what my thing was I
that's that's what I had to have in that
scene that's what I had I had to have it
I gotta get this dope I got to get this
dope for me that was the driving force
of me in that scene to get that dough
cuz I I got to shoot up I gave him what
he wanted so for me not to go down and
get that dope would have been really
just it was like okay and it'll show
curtain I've been in shows where we do
we would do two seen similar almost like
a flashback in a show and the guy was in
the show who came in he had been high on
some stuff hmm and we had two similar
scenes where the guys are sitting around
playing cards and the other people
backstage had had different costuming
for the two different scenes when they
come out he skipped the first scene of
us playing cards and went to the second
c/o and all the actors on stage in the
scene with him tried to get him back
we started rewriting and getting back to
what he was supposed to say in the first
thing he wouldn't do it so the people
behind and we opted here performing now
I mean that's when you kind of like okay
it's hard for me to stay in this now
because we got to save this and save him
and he's sitting there looking around
like this spaced out and you could hear
all the other actors backstage
scrambling to get a costume so me and
one of the other guys and leave some
stuff and I kind of casually look over
like this and the the one of the actors
gave me the sound like okay we ready and
then we went right to the next scene
then of course he's high at the end of
the night the director in the stage
manager to come out what the hell
happened he says they messed the scene
and we like what he said you said this I
said no you read the second scene he
said no no I said get the book get the
script so he got the script I said you
said this right here and I said this he
said yeah I said that's the second scene
he's like and I told him when we left
that night I gave him a ride I said they
don't know you like I know you leave
those drugs alone if you do that again
I'm gonna slap you out there I said you
can't be coming into you're high like
that I mean I did two at one time I did
a show one time where I had smoked some
stuffs weed and perform it and I said
never in my life again will I do that
again not only for me but for these
other actors and mistreat them like that
I said that that was the worst thing I
was so ashamed of myself and I didn't
really
- nothing up but I wasn't all in and
that wasn't fair to these other people
that wasn't fair to the audience that
wasn't fair to anybody and I said why
would I do that cuz I thought I was
being cute no yeah you know I know I
asked you this before about when did you
get quote good at acting but really when
did you feel like you were not mastering
the craft but that you were really
honing in and what we talked about
earlier with the Bill Duke videos
falling back into the abyss well like I
said before you know you you never
master you get good or whatever there's
always something to learn and always
take classes always stay in classes and
because of the fact it this is a work in
progress but what what I feel I think
when I felt like I was really connecting
I don't like to say I really got good I
used to I like to say when I really
started connecting to to what I was
doing I think that's when I finally
stopped trying to be perfect
see and it kind of hurt me that whole
thing I'm perfection hurt me musically
it didn't hurt me as much as an actor
and it hasn't hurt me as much as an
actor but it really hurt me musically
because I got into a thing as far as
singing in musical stuff trying to be
too perfect trying to make each note
sound whatever and that gets you in your
head and once you get into your head and
anything especially this you're in
trouble it's like what Bill Duke was
saying about stage fright that's dead
that's that ego and everything while you
out you out here judging yourself and
what you're doing it's just the same as
getting it same thing getting in your
head thinking about um that didn't sound
good or that note could have sounded
better
why are you performing that's not good
see and and when you when you drop when
you drop that perfection man
sit in and accept the fact that you're
not perfect then then you free yourself
to the point now where you can be the
actor or be the character or whatever
you free yourself then you're able to
really have fun and and let go and
explore you free you free yourself once
you free yourself in anything that's
when you get good or great or whatever
the best actors like he was saying
everybody the best actors are the ones
that free themselves to just be like
Meryl Streep Philip Seymour Hoffman
you know Daniel day-lewis I mean he's so
into that he's this he's this person
that's that's freedom even though he's
so in and locked in he's still free you
know he's free of Daniel day-lewis who's
a nice nice very nice guy and whatnot
you know normally but I mean Daniel
day-lewis wouldn't take a bowling ball
and try to kill something boy with it
pointed at it not Daniel day-lewis but
that character or the person he's being
would and he tried to do that so that's
what to me is when you become good and
when you recognize that is when you
finally accept yourself for who you are
and the fact is you not perfect because
most actors that try to do everything
perfect and just that's bad cuz then you
acting and in somebody I forgot who it
was said whatever you do don't ever let
them see you act don't ever let them see
that because then you're in trouble
because then people are looking at you
like you know you've you've seen people
perform or act insane okay that was okay
I didn't you didn't really buy it but
the person that you see like when you
see it like Christian Bale in vice or
whatever oh yeah II
he was he he was all way in he wasn't
trying to be perfect he was so busy
being a flawed person Dick Cheney is not
perfect the exchange was terrible you're
not perfect so Kristen Bell didn't have
to didn't have to try to be perfect okay
I mean if we get religious or something
the only the only person I guess closer
to being perfect was what Jesus Jesus
Christ as somebody you know what I'm
saying
I mean you know I'm saying and Jesus
Christ if you read the Bible any of that
wasn't perfect himself you know he had
flaws too
so you won't you once you get to the
point of accepting yourself and in
saying okay this is Who I am
I'm gonna just get into this as me and
I'm just gonna let it go and be free and
just let go that's when you got some
beautiful stuff going on it was great to
advise because the Cheney character the
Dick Cheney was more restrained was sort
of this anger like bubbling at the
surface where his Lynne Cheney played by
Amy Adams was great and she was
emotional and power driven and it was a
great combination right to see the two
of them together and it was just I left
that film thinking it was gonna be
lighter and more like sort of this like
sexy rock-and-roll version of it and I
was it took me like an hour to feel
normal afterwards whatever normal is
well it was pretty emotional it was it
was not a light movie it was excellent
but I really affected me now the
daughter mm-hmm she's in politics uh-huh
okay
she's a combination of the two which is
really scary okay because she has his
dark underside but she has her mother's
emotional side like like Lynne Cheney
was so she's in Congress now and she's
sitting back this sneering and saying
stuff she just got in there she just got
in there now they've elevated her all
the way up in the House of
Representatives to be the top Republican
female there's women been there in the
house on the women on the
beside they put her there because they
need somebody to counteract it or so
they think
Nancy Pelosi so they got his daughter
there who has that sinister Dick Cheney
thing but she's out with it like a
mother so it's like whoa
see then I've heard her already say some
stuff I'm like that was crazy
but I mean you know it's just it's just
funny how that is it's just funny and
and and getting back to being an actor
being able to like Bill Duke said it's
like falling into darkness backwards to
do that it's like that whole you know
that experiment if you haven't been in
one of those cycle it's like a actor
where you trust things you know oh yeah
you know somebody catch you
yeah whatever you know it's like that
we're okay you gotta let yourself and be
honest with you it's hard to let
yourself go when somebody gotta catch
you I mean I don't care how great of an
actor you I it's hard to fall back and
you got somebody back here trying to
catch you that you don't know well you
don't know if they got me to catch your
big fat ass like me it's like okay I'm
still okay I'm I can't let go to this
you know cuz I'm scared I'm gonna hit my
damn head but what he said was basically
once you're able to just free fall
backwards then you they're you know so
so it's a little more work I got to do
you know speaking of older and this is a
sensitive topic but we'll just go there
and if you want to stop we can we were
talking earlier about a lot of women
that you've known that ever been they've
been actors and it may be 40-plus they
go home
and so we kind of talked about how I'm
not saying all females but some we get
our identity from being cute or sexy or
whatever and then when society tells us
that's done with then we don't have that
same identity anymore so you said that
maybe for men it's easier of course
because they can kind of be in this
character mode do you think women can
transition to a character mode I think
women have the skills to do that but did
not allowed to
see this is a this is unfortunately this
is a this is a male-driven industry and
particularly a young male driven
industry and and it's unfortunate and to
see the fact that a lot of women are not
allowed to do that then being honest a
lot of women can't do that because they
don't want to do this sure we talked
about that see they and it's not I don't
wanna see a lot but some women don't
want to do that because they they they
their looks and whatnot was so powerful
and prevalent in their work that to be
older they couldn't do it they can't do
it
you have exceptions you have Glenn Close
in the movie that new movie she wanted
to glow the wife oh my gosh I haven't
seen it yet I just got screener okay
okay
see there's women like that in of course
Meryl Streep mm-hmm and you have some
some other like oh what's the name Helen
Mirren oh yeah
Judi Dench a lot of these women and they
are fantastic because they accepted
their their their aging and also they
were given opportunities to age that's
true a lot of women have given these
opportunities and I think that's wrong I
think it's wrong that the industry is
set up where a man is allowed to get old
and fat or whatever and women aren't
well not you don't say I'm not yeah no I
agree but we talked about earlier that
that even with men they can be held to
those standards as well and then sort of
the pretty boy you know hunk then can no
longer play that anymore but we talked
about maybe the quirky types that were
never really that yeah whether they were
male or female they can kind of bridge
that gap to playing an older quirkier
version because it wasn't reliant on
the sexiness factor well you know all
throughout all throughout Hollywood from
the very beginning of the you know the
early 1900s and the Golden Age of
Hollywood that's been the problem with
men and women the beautiful people
that's been a problem a lot of those
people committed suicide the women and a
man killed themselves some of them just
quit like Greta Garbo you know I want to
be alone that woman left Hollywood at
the height of her career in elected
early 40s and just left and moved off to
New York and for what 50 60 years was a
recluse you know in a you know apartment
in on Fifth Avenue somewhere you know
for the rest of her life and it's just
weird but and and this is something I
found and I'm fortunate it affected I
might have been the leading man maybe
once or twice but even as that little
boy in the first third grade or whatever
I was like no I don't something in me
recognized no I don't want to be that
leading man I want to be the evil Sultan
has got the character see how something
to me it hit me even at that age
something happened and it was I'm like
what eight or nine or seven or eight or
whatever I'm a little kid but something
in me
whatever it was said no you and I've
always been like that I've been in
showed I've been at a few shows where I
was the lead and I was like oh but it I
always I always excelled and got great
reviews or good reviews as that quirky
character even if it was a lead
character it was still somebody that
wasn't heroic pretty guy you know I've
never been there because I don't look
like that
so what I'm saying is it's been great
like that and I've accepted it but see
and and I find this especially in in
voiceover and animation where a lot of
my female friends
or actors you know female actors even
even though they are not being seen on
camera a lot of them can't break it down
using just the voice to be crank me only
and a lot of them that can't do that
because they won't they can't accept
that in themselves and I had a friend of
mine who was trying to do animation who
got frustrated and I finally had to tell
her I said why don't you stop being
good-looking I said this is this is
nobody see your face say why can't you
just be that Craig Lee oh heck no and
and seriously and she like and finally
she said you're right now she's it's
hard to do animation anyway but she's
worked better and she's doing better now
because I said they can't see your face
you very attractive woman
and then there's some really really
gorgeous women that I know that's
playing all the animation stuff all the
different characters the woman is
playing the new Rocky from the rocky and
bullwinkle Tara Strong is very
attractive woman
very attractive hey I mean because she
can she her mine and seeing this
business you have to you have to break
it down you have to and when I say break
it down you got to just break it down I
did a short film for a guy and he said
man I need you to play this homeless guy
said cool he like said yeah he said now
you gonna be over here I said name I
gonna be in that refrigerator box right
there he said yeah that's it
great I'm in there I got garbage all
around me and I'm laying in there and
it's like yeah because that cool because
it's like I get to break and be free I
get to you know and I mean I've studied
and been around and seeing enough
homeless people
terrible to know and understand you know
what that is and I've seen it I've
talked to people like that
you know I've talked to people I used to
do that in Chicago I used to sit over in
Grant Park and and sit there you know
and sometimes I have a eat my little
sandwich or something and they would
come up say American brother could you
help me out yeah okay I say sit down for
a thing I've talked to these people and
you find out all kind of weird stuff
that they've gone through they're very
bright a lot of them mostly those are
the ones that become the craziest
there's a lot of Einsteins walking
through through the parking out there on
the side of the road it's a because
because this thing see the guys is not
too smart
you they stick somebody else it might
end up in jail but you get a lot of
smart brilliant people out there on the
side of the road standing out there when
you come down the ramp on the freeway
they got a sign up something went on and
something happened in their life is
usually some kind of a relationship
situation something like that that's
snapped him out I sit there I just talk
to people you know and I'm like wow
that's crazy that's Wow
so when the gas theater you got to play
this homeless guy so cool and he said
man Wow
I said yeah I said he homeless but
ethylamine he you don't have a brain he
got problem he got stuffed it you gotta
have a problem the end about this
something went wrong I went to school
with a boy who was a troubled kid in
school and in junior high school and I'm
here livid I forgot his last name but he
had a strange look that you couldn't
forget and I remember seeing him years
later and I looked he didn't really
notice me but look that's it that's it
and he was basically out on the streets
Tanana
it kind of lost it I was like he was a
problem in school and that's when I was
I was saying I think earlier when I was
saying about a lot of people especially
in this modern day are forced into being
or trying to put them in places where
they shouldn't be and he had a he had a
mechanical aptitude but he was being
forced to become a college preparatory
person we're just not getting back we're
just now getting back to putting people
in schools and trades people make good
money in these trees
I mean plumbers and oh yeah electricians
have something go wrong with your house
see how much you paying them to come fix
it and they doing 15 10 15 of these jobs
a day they got it down within a half
hour and you paying a couple hundred
dollars I mean you know we forced people
in the stuff like that we forced people
into nine-to-five jobs like they were
trying to force me into same thing this
is a trade I mean I'm a tradesman and I
was forced into being a nine-to-five you
know college preparatory person yeah I
mean I had a bility to learn I got a
damn good SAT scores okay but I was like
smart enough to say I'm not supposed to
be here and lost wives and girlfriends
and family mad at me but I'm like okay
you be mad get glad scratch your ass cuz
I'm getting nutty and so expression from
down south you know it's like no you
know uh-uh
I Know Who I am I know what I'm supposed
to do and this is what I always say the
people especially aspiring actors cuz I
get friends of mine said oh my um
my nephew was coming out there and can
you give him some advice I said yeah I
can give me advice I say when they
called me I'll say okay how bad do you
want this well you know I want to do
this but I still want to have something
to fall back on I said well no you don't
need to do this I asked you how bad do
you want this and you telling me about
trying to find a job to fall back on
why are you falling back like Bill Duke
said if you falling back you got to fall
into the abyss you falling back on a job
then why don't you just keep that job
then you don't have to fall I tell him I
said how bad do you want this like my
friend and say how bad do you want it
bad enough for somebody saying if you do
that I will kill you well kill me then
cuz I'm gonna do this I said this is
what this life is this is no bed of
roses you're gonna get rejected 99.9
percent of the time and it's gonna be
whether they don't like you or you
[ __ ] up the audition which happens
because you know we all do that you know
or the fact that you know you look like
somebody that uh yeah I have women
clients say you know you look like the
guy that I dated and I hated him you
know what can you do you can't do
nothing we're dead you're gonna get all
kind of crazy stuff in this business why
you don't get hired or they gonna say
you know I've audition for stuff what
they say they decided to use a woman I'm
like okay or I decided to go weight or
they decided to go Asian what I decided
to go Latino what I decided to do this
or we want somebody gay or we want
somebody a transgender all kind of stuff
you're gonna get rejected like this so
you can't sit there and you gotta just
say okay keep it moving keep it moving
cuz that's how it is
the skin got to be thick we got spots
instead it's not thick we all got points
where's like um like me we all get there
sometime you snap out of it
you know and then you go to the next
audition or get next one you booked it's
like yeah and then you know that one
after that it's like oh yeah that's just
this life and I loved it I mean I've
never never ever since I've been in this
business and I'm continued straight up
honestly I've never had a things quit
I've never had that because I knew that
me going back home what am I gonna do I
can't do nothing else I can't do
anything but this and be successful at
it or really do it I can't work no job I
mean I was um my first job for the
insurance company I would I was there
and I got sick the first day because I I
don't like coffee and I had never really
drink coffee but everybody was drinking
coffee we're gonna go take a break and
have a coffee so I said oh okay is that
what I'm supposed to do so I went and
had a coffee I'm like oh so I spend half
the day in the bathroom sitting on the
toilet like this and they knew I was
sick and they were laughing oh he's sick
so finally I come out at the end of the
day we all own the elevator on the 20th
floor coming now and they say get to the
bottom of the dope and he says well just
think we got to do this all over again
tomorrow and I'm like oh [ __ ] you can do
over rejection and how much that hurts
or you can deal with office politics and
you have to be around a person a group
of people for eight hours a day that you
know it doesn't matter what you do
you're not gonna get the right end of
the stick and so which is which is
harder oh well
dad oh that is much harder
oh I whatever me getting rejected oh
well see cool there's a little trick
that you have to play with yourself as
an actor okay it's when you get rejected
you you can't you can't say this out
loud but you have to think this and what
you have to think and I tell people and
they say really I said you have to carry
yourself when you don't get the job as
if it's stupid as hell to not book me
for that job that job is gonna be a
disaster because I didn't get it you
have to have it in your mind to the it's
a fine line between me and egotist doing
nuts or just saying okay knows they love
you know that whole thing well that was
their loss and you can't just say that
you have to really believe that and see
after years and years of this business I
believe it I mean and I don't say it to
people war but I just had this state
loss the best for this I believe it and
that's how you carry yourself through
now whether I'm the best and not that's
just on somebody else or whatever but I
have to say this for myself you know
wow I didn't get it Wow
oh I've been in auditions where in a
callback I walk in the room and I can
instantly tell that the director does
not like me and and when I leave I'm
like I'm bad because I get mad at it
because I'm like well why the hell did
you have me in here wasting my time not
Showtime
why does he waste my time if you don't
like me then why you got me here and you
get that sometimes
I've been in rooms where they love me
they love me they have me said can you
go back out and come back in and they
have you come back in with another group
and they have you and they spotlight you
in all the groups and you get nothing
absolutely nothing
I had auditions already had me do it a
hundred different ways say it like this
say it like that and you are happy when
you supposed to be an apple and you
standing there like this then you say
the line and I do all this different
stuff and it's night yeah and I leave
out and I'm like okay and then the other
actors that leave with you said man it
really likes you I said yeah okay
and they said what I said okay
and don't get it it didn't be like then
there's been auditions where you go in
thank you and then you're like well I
didn't get that one the next day your
agent says you got it I said god what
the one you went for yes that's it
really
I said oh they loved you then you get on
set and then I'll ask people I said what
was going on you you the director if
once they get did like you say well you
didn't I didn't know you I don't think
you like me says I love you I didn't
need to see any more for you you're the
first choice and I wanted you all alone
so it was just okay then you get them
aware you know like I said it's all kind
of crazy stuff and if you get yourself
caught up and all of that it'll drive
you nuts so you got to go in and do it
and when you come out sin well I know
I'm good at this and I'm the best for it
so whatever happens happens I don't know
I'm the best so what if I get it great
if I don't they're lost and that's how
you have to do this and people say oh
that's not nice no you don't have to be
nice that's what you're thinking inside
and that's what I tell people and
yelling actors I know that that they're
getting the business they say oh okay
because most people quit this because
they can't handle the rejection because
this you get more rejection than
anything as an actor if I told you some
of the stuff I was up for that I didn't
get it's like wow big stuff I mean team
TV shows starring in movies all kind of
stuff major stuff and everybody your
agents and managers everybody's excited
oh yes and you know and they say to me
they say you don't seem excited and I
say well because I haven't gotten a job
yet they said well you did according
said you did a great job I'm like yeah
well you did do a great job I do so it's
like okay call me and tell me I got the
job did I get excited when they say you
got the job like oh I got it cool okay
but other than that no and then this
that's that's though that's the thing I
try to tell young people or new actors
or people coming out here I say study
your stuff stay in class keep working
and if you got to get a job get a job if
you got to have something to pay your
bills why are you working at this do
that but try to get something that's
flexible don't don't get out here and
borrow money and have people want to
kill you because I know people that
borrow money to survive out here and and
and people want to kill them because
this is actors out here that will try to
live on you or borrow on you and do
stuff and they don't realize they don't
want to realize I want to kill you I
gave you this money and I need that
money or whatever you know so don't do
that get you a little job or something I
don't borrow nothing like that I don't
know I don't borrow from nobody I don't
have to at this point but I mean I don't
borrow nothing from nobody like that I
might borrow I borrow from my mom and
dad in them of course you know but I'm
not gonna borrow from none of these
friends of mine because I know that is
tight for them now I got to hand that
money back don't worry I got this chick
coming and when I get it I'm gonna pay
you first and you know I'm at a point
now it's like wait a minute you gonna
pay me first I'm broke and you broke you
gonna get that check and you're gonna
pay me first and your rent is due
hey can you loan me $1,000 I'll pay you
back
I'll pay you $250 a month and I say well
why don't you do this why don't you take
the next 4 months and save the $250 each
month and you got a thousand that woman
wanted to choke and kill me
that woman wanted to grab me and throw
me on my head but I said oh hell no I
don't get thousand dollars